all right Sidney's with us in Nevada hi
Sidney welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
your question for dr. John hi how are
you guys great how can we help okay so
I'm in a little bit of a sticky
situation so I'm in my mid-20s I live in
Nevada I attend to I go to a four-year
public university in Reno and I still
live with my parents so my parents
biggest goal for me is to not to worry
about any bills just pay through school
as much as you can
and they'll take care of the rest so my
dad and I we did that bloody hand I was
a teenager I noticed it's been getting
progressively worse you know whenever he
gets angry at me he cusses me out he's
always you know threatened me to kick up
you know you know I need to find you
know another place to stay
he's always think I'm ungrateful even he
were before and I'm just getting really
tired of it you know it's you know I've
been listening to Dave Ramsey for a few
years now I know he is a big advocate
for not taking student debts or anything
like that but it's to the point now it's
like I'd rather just take out a loan and
just get on my own instead of constantly
being verbally abusive on nothing so I'm
just tired I don't know what to do I you
know talk to my grandparents and they're
just saying you know just basically suck
it up you know like you can't afford to
live like you're live on your own you
know I just I'm gonna catch-22 I really
need help so that's my question for the
day is what should I do
so you you number one I want to thank
you for your bravery and Colin and I
know that that's that's a hard thing to
do and you have to look in the mirror
and say this the one guy on planet earth
who was assigned to treat me right is
not right and so I'm sorry it's mixed
emotions too you know so he yell at me
and then the next day he pretends like
nothing happens yeah that's what a bully
does promotion that's what a jerk
doesn't sort of bully doesn't so what I
want you to hear me say is you know
you're gonna create a boundary you're
gonna create a plan to walk away from
that
because no one gets to talk to you that
way cuz you're worth more than that and
so here's what we're gonna do you gave
me two plans which is either go to
school and take out a loan or to stay at
home and be treated this way and have
your school paid for what I want to tell
you there's a third option which is you
may have to take a minute whether it's a
semester or whether it's a semester in a
summer term and save up some money and
get a job where you can earn some cash
and then get a small apartment and it
may be that you're going to transfer
schools and make it there's all kinds of
alternative plans when you're in your
mid-20s that every semester feels like a
hundred years and so as an old guy here
I want you to know I have started and
stopped more semesters I think I started
four or five different graduate degrees
and it switched and changed so when
you're old and you're married and you
got two wackadoo little kids running
around and your life laughing and
smiling which is going to be the
trajectory for you I want you to also
not get not lose sight of the the future
here over a semester over nine nine
months is that fair right you do have to
put some paper up into a paper and make
a plan make a decision and make a plan
and put an exit strategy for yourself
what you're a single are you in I'm a
sophomore the major that I'm trying to
pursue they were saying that it takes
about five years and you're so crap and
you're studying what supply chain
management is not a five year degree
it's a four year degree
that's just everybody takes five because
they're lazy and they don't have a plan
but I got to tell you I got lots of
supply chain guys on our team they got
their degrees in four years it's a
matter of fact if you're studying supply
chain you ought to be able to execute a
plan that kind of part of its good
pretty much anyways just good practice
but anyway aside from that you're
halfway through and so here's what you
do your first money goal is to create an
income that you can live on your second
money goal and you need to map that out
exactly like John said so you can leave
your second money goal is to create
additional income on top of living that
allows you to go to school
the second goal might take a might mean
you take a semester off what you on
saying and that's better
quitting school and never going back is
better than what you're doing right now
that's right
no school preschool is worth what you're
going through
absolutely there's no abuse scholarship
out there no